again the biggest problem with the women
in the space is their solipsism doesn't
allow them to fully comprehend what men
struggle with and that's what men are
looking for that's what that's what
they're looking for when they watch
these women talk like they're they want
these women to understand them
they want them to
see their plight and agree with them
they're not there to level themselves up
they're not there to do 25 push-ups and
make an extra 25 000 this year uh create
some style for themselves they're there
to just watch the gals talk and as
you're doing it you're essentially
simping because it's an unfair Exchange
and they're getting their attention the
validation of the money out of you know
whatever it is that you're throwing
their way fine
but again they don't care about your
struggles they're at the Finish Line
picking the winner women are not King
makers they want to find a king these
Queens they don't want to be king makers
they want to find Kings that's how they
are right
and of course you know their Pastor smv
they're entering you know the space
um and it's at it's at the wrong time
there's no woman in her early 20s that
you're going to capture and fix her
before she runs through a bunch of guys
makes a whole bunch of bad decisions
they just don't exist but it's very very
easy for them even young ones you know
to get a bunch of microphones and
cameras and have people sit around and
just talk about Concepts that I talked
about years ago with a bunch of other
guys you know
anyway there's no red pill female
unicorn so I hope that point you know
has been made clear
but Beauty gets views right so whether
you're the guy running the podcast
putting gals at the table
that beauty will get views whether
you're a gal sitting in a room and
they're generally
it's weird because there's a spectrum it
doesn't even matter if they're very
attractive or if they're very average in
fact I would probably argue the average
at best
to quote with Kevin Kevin say animals I
love that line
I'd probably argue the average at best
gals that are regurgitating lines
sounding like the guys but offering no
new Solutions or anything like that
really just saying what's already been
said they probably get more views than
the ones that you sit at the table with
the hot girls
I don't think the hot girls are as
relatable to the guys that are really
struggling anyway
um
now I said earlier when I was reading
the Tweet a lot of these guys when I was
in the space and this is one of the
things that really bugged me because
we pretty it was pretty much unanimous
why are they here there's only one or
two of them who cares yeah they're
probably dangerous and they're leading
guys you know down the wrong path let
them put their their boobs out and sell
their courses who cares you know only
fans for the red pill let them do it
whatever
and they said that they would never
collaborate with them strangely though
in the last year there's been a lot of
collaborations done with guys in the man
of swamp with the the gals
why
because it gets the attention it brings
the eyeballs into the show they figured
that out right fresh and fit started
that sequence of events and then the
other people watching that were like huh
that works
it's got a big table and some
microphones and some chairs and some
lighting and we'll all go do the same
sort of thing so you want to start up a
podcast that's how you make it
successful there you go I just gave away
the cheat codes
now I'll be honest I think a lot of
these gals are really trying to see
things from a man's point of view but
they just unless you have male levels of
testosterone a penis and you've dealt
with the rejection and the difficulties
that men deal with in life you'll just
never understand it you just you just
don't have a clue unfortunately I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out